une rentrée dans les lycées franciliens
placés sous le signe du pouvoir d'achat
c'est le sujet phare du moment la région
n'augmentera pas le prix des cantines
tout comme du repas à 50 centimes
d'euros c'est une tarification spéciale
mise en place pour les lycéens des
foyers les plus modestes elle est
arrivée du Pass imaginaire cette carte
de transport à 350 euros par an seront
également gelés annonce de la région les
jeunes pourront aussi profiter avec ce
Pass imaginaire davantage culture des
réductions notamment dans des sites
partenaires du territoire enfin chaque
élève des lycées publics se verra
remettre à son entrée en seconde un
ordinateur personnel tous les manuels
scolaires ils seront chargés ils seront
disponibles ils pourraient être
conservés jusqu'à la fin des études
secondaires la région
Île-de-France vous le savez c'est une
région très riche mais très inégalitaire
et l'éducation c'est la clé de
l'ascenseur social et moi je ne veux pas
que les familles doivent rogner sur
l'éducation de leurs enfants et nous
avions malheureusement une très grosse
fracture numérique au sein des familles
franciliennes c'est pour ça que cette
fourniture ordinateur gratuit donne à
chaque lycéen les outils numériques pour
réussir l'Île-de-France va accélérer
également la mise en oeuvre de son plan
d'urgence des lycées de 6 milliards
d'euros il a permis cette année la
livraison d'établissements rénovés comme
le lycée franco-allemand de Buck et le
lycée international de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye 600 millions
d'euros supplémentaires vont être
débloqués par la région pour créer des
places supplémentaires plus 30600 d'ici
2028 avec 11 lices et 9 et 6 extensions
dans la région un lycée neuf vera le
jour entre Poissy et Conflans et nous
voulons aussi une extension de place de
200 places dans le ruralisme du côté de
Bonnières on va on va réfléchir à
comment est-ce qu'on on peut faire une
offre de lycée dans le rural yvinois
autre sujet sur la table le wifi dans
100% des lycées la promesse n'avait pas
pu être tenue l'an passé elle devrait
l'être au 15 octobre l'écologie le plan
solaire vise à équiper sans lisser de
l'Île-de-France de panneaux
photovoltaïques et ceux et d'ici 2024 13
leçons déjà sur le territoire et puis
sur le volet sécurité la région va
doubler le nombre de brigades régionales
de sécurité dans les lycées elle passe
de 5 à 10 équipes soit 50 agents et
depuis le déploiement de ce dispositif
en 2019 1900 interventions de
sécurisation ont lieu dans les lycées
franciliens à la demande des chefs
d'établissements